mons achats pour l'instant on va rigoler
et surtout on va dénoncer question va
dénoncer il est décidé cyril chaque
semaine de commencer cette chronique
avec un dossier sur vous non alors la
semaine dernière c'était marrant tous un
peu jeune aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo
cyril que faisiez-vous le dimanche 28
juin dernier aux environs de 15h à peu
près je ne sais pas tennis à moi je vais
vous le dire
alors michel leader mais c'est pas il
sait pas c'est pas mal à nice non oui
syrie n'était pas trader
regardez bien la vidéo visiblement quand
on fait du sport on n'a pas tous les
noms
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
marquez s'est longtemps nous avons
montré notre légende qu'est ce qui se
passe dans sa tête à ce moment là et je
jure que c'est vrai je sais pas j'étais
j'étais bien c'est une robe est bien
chaud et je me tuera aller bada désolé
même entendu mais comment est-ce qu'on
centre l'adversaire que des bonnes
choses entre ce que les gens ont adoré
déstabiliser et je peux vous dire gagner
la partie web à ça on est obligé de
gagner avec ça les gens n'ont pas envie
de voir deux allaient sceller la semaine
dernière j'avais montré les chroniqueurs
qui s'était incrusté dans le clip de thé
au lavabo
ouais en me baladant dans les loges
cette semaine je me suis rendu compte
que les chroniqueurs s'amusait beaucoup
avec le fonds vert regardez sur incrusté
dans plein d'émissions pelo oui regardez
les chroniqueurs alors et vous dire ça
je vous raconte tout c'était le mardi
détournement qu'est devenu internet
produits etc comme on l'a fait on s'est
dit pourquoi pas le mettre dans le bon
jour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
bonjour ça va bien tout va bien quand
vous êtes avec moi je me sens bien à
temps après l'émission tu vas voir ce
que je vais te faire ce sera quoi le
programme je te bouffe le cul comme des
faits à jean mi vous êtes amusé ce vous
plaît aussi ça va te plaire mon petit
cochon grecque
place à une rencontre rock'n'roll
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas sûr qu'ils aient beaucoup de
jeunes femmes qui trouve ça super ah
ouais tu vas voir
après danse avec les stars matt singer
et star à mu tf1 lance sa nouvelle
émission danse avec une star masqué à nu
[Applaudissements]
la police est là
je crois vraiment que c'est rihanna je
pense à guillaume canet moi j'aimerais
que ça soit je ne sais pas jean dujardin
[Musique]
non jean pascal de tp un pays ouvert à
tous
it's amazing nicolas pernikoff et bien
sûr notre daniel moreau d'amour à lesmo
suri d'autres choses oui cette semaine
pour faire une surprise à viennay
qu'était notre invité eh bien on
recevait son frère louis edouard bureau
j'adorais aussi
alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas dormir
au c'est un très grand écrivain oui oui
c'est un monstre de la littérature et
pour faire la prière cri le lion qui a
pétri à gaza exactement
justement il a fait la promotion de son
livre dans plusieurs émissions dans
plusieurs chaînes et franchement y'a
rien à dire
la promo de baba
[Rires]
frère à côté chez et loire bureau c'est
vous happer bureau et ouais on malraux
c'est ce qu'on entendait quoi office
douar bureau alors vous êtes né vous en
1992 il ya votre premier roman
s'intitule le lion chants prières
mushkin adeptes j'ai pensé ou au
douanier rousseau une sorte d' afrique
fantasmée est ce que ça vous parle
il est né comme ça roman placée sous le
double signe de joseph kessel et d'henry
de monfreid d' et mbm radio est la
meilleure chanson française et un
souffle lyrique qui nous emmène dans une
dans un pays imaginaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec une nouvelle pas si
alors je vous cache pas que j'ai
brainstorm et toute la semaine pour
trouver le titre ça s'appelle 50
secondes inside de pmp témoin oui est
foutu de la gueule de kid de personnes
et on commence tout de suite avec
nicolas pernikoff très coquin cette
semaine on continue avec berlin 20e aux
copains du mec a visiblement des petits
soucis avec son zizi
visiblement ça parle miss france dans
les loges de tpm paix qui dérange 0 6me
télé
visiblement sur la deuxième radio de
france exem le partage la brienne il est
très bon je ne suis pas jaloux brothers
avec des finitions et puis nicolas
pernikoff qui visiblement a quelques
petits soucis de santé
si tu regardes et puis on a vu aussi une
isabelle morini-bosc toujours aussi
souple a vu les minots c'est dégueulasse
mais la roma ya toutes ces couches
culottes en tout cas tout le monde est
prêt pour les nrj music awards
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
et on laisse le mot de la fin à nicolas
pernikoff au racket lui tenir les très
belles non je suis désolé
daniel mots là ali ali ali ben ben je
suis d'accord avec daniel c'est une
belle femme arrêtée alors là moi je suis
pas d'accord c'est une belle femme
et comme on le dit à chaque fois mais
voilà quoi mais c'est vrai dans mes
mails et daniel est réjoui jeudi à l'afp
sylvie tellier
c'est un peu dur là j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un peut lui préférer rsa a été
nicolas pernikoff et file dans la phrase
et j'adore à nicolas on va te fasse
vraiment la série lauragais fait moins
joli sourire
normalement tu l'entends que dans faites
entrer l'accusé
les chineurs de temps modernes on y va
on continue avec une moi je lis sourire
au quotidien avec une pastille qu'on a
connu dans la nuit coup ça y est oui un
gars une kelly alors avant c'était entre
jean michel et kelly maintenant kelly a
changé de cible n'ont jamais fait sentir
au regarder comment ça se fritent tout
est entre les deux entre castaldi et
kelis à ce fric touriste à ce ça se bat
[Musique]
pour le moment du début d'émission j'te
défonce et je vous ai tous même des
conseils que je protège un jardin elle
mesure 12 mètres 50
et tu veux qu'on parle de ce qui se
passe dans ton slip tu remplis d'eau
jour là on va se revoir
g
alors que la croisette on perd là
bizarrement ouais il est en train de
masser le cul d'un mec alors franchement
c'est improbable quand il était en
string j'étais vêtue à la regarder
l'ancien star ibère en fait à tous il
voit là je vois les deux ans le fils bon
ça à verser amenant ses gros si ça c'est
pas humain évolue chez mon frère quant à
lui né vers notre histoire pour le moins
c'est un non événement dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose que vous sachiez ces
coquilles et benjamin sont récompensés
bassam à karan et kelly dans l'émission
face the mais ma femme pour être plus
exactement quel est votre femme aurore
merci et chez vous ébahir or qui avait
ramené l'avancé avec benjamin vous aimer
d'amour
vous êtes très drôle tous les ce régal
en loge les deux quand ils sont non
c'est incroyable frères et soeurs direct
de son grand frère c'est ça c'est
d'épouser mais même dans la vie c'est ça
pour de vrai il est très bons conseils
benjamin c'est un amour toujours un oeil
sur kenny s'est mis à les mots chéri
cyril qu'on a d'autres pour terminer le
problème c'est qu'il a toujours un oeil
sur vous un instant puisque cyril on
sait que cette intrigante animateurs un
producteur doit donc les semaines un
danseur même un chanteur on l'a vu il ya
un instant mais si vous avez rajouté sur
toile abrutis dis pas ça le vous me
l'étais pas mais par contre je sais que
j'ai ajouté une nouvelle corde à votre
arc cette semaine commentateur politique
regardez cyril quand ils écoutent le
discours d' emmanuel macron elle est
très agitée
d'où cette diminution va aller plus vite
que la d re la forme va dire que sauver
les commerces ouverts bravo ouais on va
pouvoir aller jouer au bowling librairie
de rassembler un grand nombre de paires
sont pas les musées j'espère resteront
fermés je suis un fou de musées - débat
a love le confinement pourrait être le
jure sur la torah qu'à nouveau goûter
lecture est essentiel jure sur le coran
à notre les activités scolaires
on peut la saint barth pour l'accueil
des enfants devant les héros seront à
nouveau excuse moi je vais parler mais
on peut prendre le bateau deux minutes
je te veux te parler deux minutes au
privé on peut prendre paul à saint barth
attend il en train de me remercier la
maison créée voilà merci il trouver de
nouveaux ils n'ont pas de ski à noël
mais on va jeter on achète une station
[Musique]
rassemblement au pire des cas je vais
comme à dubaï cheikh une station à la
maison avec nicollin
ce cochon tout cas merci avoue cyril je
devais partir au ski qui devait partir
ce qu'ils n'ont personne et ben merci
pour vous allez merci